scholar johansen's lawsuit against
disney for breach of contract is one of
the hottest topics in the entertainment
industry right now
and it's not hard to understand why
there are many compelling dynamics at
play
on the one hand you have a rich and
successful movie star quibbling over the
idea that 20 million dollars plus
streaming royalties isn't fair
compensation conversely you have a major
conglomerate arguing that they are
trying to give fans a safer way to watch
the film amid another dangerous surge of
coven 19.
it's a complex legal issue regardless of
which side of the fence you're on you
probably have your own opinion on the
subject
well you're not alone they bautista is
not only the first celebrity to respond
to the spat between johansson and disney
he's also a prominent figure in the mcu
and he had some very interesting things
to say on the matter dave bautista has
become a popular figure in hollywood
especially for his role as drax the
destroyer in the guardians of the galaxy
movies the success of which has led to
action turns such as this year's army of
the dead on netflix
he's also known for being quite
outspoken for a celebrity of his stature
and fans were dismayed to learn
back in may that he won't be reprising
his beloved character after the third
and final guardians of the galaxy movie
citing his reason for throwing in the
towel being that he is expecting
everything to start saggy in any second
now
in any case the fact that bautista is
getting ready to finish up his time in
the mcu didn't stop him from throwing in
his two cents about this latest disney
controversy on social media
his tweet punctuated by a shrug emoji
reads told him they should have made a
drax movie but no
pans seemed to be mixed on his attempt
at levity as of this video the tweet has
over 20 thousand likes and 1700 retweets
but in the replies while many followers
are chuckling at his tongue-in-cheek
humor there are also many others who
believe it to be in poor taste
i know what you're thinking people
overreacting on twitter no way
but yes it really happened one commenter
replied with bad tweet
delete please another replied with a
little sarcasm of their own saying
yeah because there's a huge lack of male
superhero movies i know it's a joke but
it's a bad one
especially now that disney is trying to
portray scarlett as a bad person when
they clearly broke the contract
there were even several chiming in
pointing to what they saw as sexism
inherent in the lawsuit summing it up by
tweeting
this tweet ain't it scarlett's contract
was breached period and she's more than
entitled to the damages they've cost her
she spent a decade creating one of the
most iconic characters suffered sexism
and hyper-sexualization and now this
crap
she deserved better other twitter users
were more supportive of bautista's joke
one expressed interest in a potential
drax centric film tweeting i would have
taken my butt to the theater to see a
drax movie repeatedly
another user also backed this up with a
serious suggestion that instead of drax
getting a movie you should get a disney
plus series
not a movie but a tv show based on the
infinity watch comics
i believe it is a better fit for a track
spin-off if you can mr boutique to try
to push for that with disney
sell it is one more mcu show to promote
their streaming service
either way the situation playing out
between johansen and disney is certainly
complicated more than just some jokes
and reacts on twitter can explain
and it may very well only get more
complicated as it plays out in court
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
mcu controversies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one